Hello and welcome to this next video of our exercise. In this we are going to be
adding in the functionality to lock and unlock the door and make it so that it can be
and make it so that we can see it reflected in the color of the light
on the actor. So I'm back in the engine now and in this video we're going to be creating
a function which will change the light's color so that we can see if it is locked or unlocked.
And we're going to be putting in the functionality that will make that work.
So the first thing that we're going to want to do on this is we're going to want to talk
about variables. Because we're going to need to know if a door is locked or unlocked.
And we want you to save that. So we're going to save that data in a variable.
So that's all that a variable is. It's an allocation of memory on the computer where
we can save data. So in the left hand side here you can see we have the variable section.
And if I push plus it will create a new variable. Now in this case we created a transform.
You might have a boolean but let's talk through what the different types of variable are.
So if you look up in the top right hand corner in the details panel we have a drop down
with all of the different types of variables that we can have.
Now the first one is a boolean. And what a boolean is is it is simply a one or a zero.
And this is really useful for us to tell if something is true or false. So in this case
we're going to use a boolean and we're going to call the variable locked. And so what this is
going to do is if it is locked we'll set the boolean to true. If it is unlocked the boolean
will be false. Now let's have a quick look at the other variables. So as we go down the list
here we have a bunch of green ones and these are all numeric of varying different sizes.
The ones that we're probably going to see the most is the float which allows us to have a floating
point number like 0.5 or 0.2 and so on. This is great for percentages or anything we
need to get very very specific. We also have an integer. An integer is going to be a whole
number so it's only going to be one two three four. We're not going to have any floating points.
It's great for counting things or knowing how many times you've been around the loop.
Next we have these pinky sort of purpley ones and these are all different forms of text.
We won't worry too much about that. This one underneath that we have vectors rotators and
transforms. These are structs of floats and I'll create a transform so that we can look into it.
But I think one of the easiest ways to understand what a transform is is if we go into
the viewport and select anything for example our actor the transform will be the first thing
that appears in the details panel and that is our location rotation and scale.
All of these are structs of floats which have three values one denoting x y and z
so that we can figure out things in the 3d space. So if I was to look at the variable
I'll take my transform variable drag it in. First choice I have is get or set. Now
if when you get a variable all you are is reading the value that is inside that variable.
When you set a variable you are changing the value which is inside that variable.
And these both look a little bit different. So our get does not have an execution pin
and just as an output pin. Our set has to be connected up via an execution pin
and it has an input and an output. Now we talked about this being a struct.
A struct stands for structure which is a combination of variables. So if I come in here
I right-hand click and go split struct pin you can see that I'll get location rotation and scale.
I can even go further to split the struct pin again and that will give us x y and z which
will be green which is our floats that are recombined and so that gives us our our
transforms. Now I will show you one last part of variables which are worth referencing
and that is references. So if I search for example in here for actor you will see that we have the
object type actor. When I come to the right I have four options. An object reference,
a class reference, and a soft objects and soft class. Don't worry too much about them.
But the blue object reference is a connection to an instance of that. So this would be a connection
to a specific door which was in the level or a specific actor. The class reference is a reference
to the template that's on disk. So that would give us things like the default values
and allow us to spawn something using that class. But the light blue ones is an instant
reference. The purple ones is a class reference. Okay so I'm going to delete that variable
and let's create our function. Now functions are very useful because it allows us to write
a piece of code and then rather than having to have the entire code we can just call that
function and it will do everything which is inside that function. That's making a reusable
piece of code. And to create a function I'm coming into the left hand side here and I'm pushing
plus under function. And I am gonna call this function change light color. As I create the
function you can see it has automatically opened them up. We have our input pin here. For this
I want to drag in our point light. But let's have a quick look at the point light in the level.
Now the Polinite itself has got a very large attenuation radius. So I am going to reduce
that down. Let's try 100. That's a lot smaller. I'm going to increase the intensity as well to
make it brighter. So that's what our light looks like at the moment. Set to white.
It's coming up as green. And pile. There you go. So this is what our light looks like at the moment.
Right. So the change light color. I've got a reference to my point light and as you can see
this is blue. That means it's a reference to an instance of a point light. I'm going to drag
off the point light and I am going to search for light color. And you can see that I have
a get and a set light color. And we want to change it. So we're going to go for set.
Delete the duplication. I'm going to plug that into our light color. Now we have an input
pin for our light color here. But I want to base the color off of our boolean locked.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to drag out and type in select. And under select
you can see that we have a select color. I'm going to do that. And now you can see that we have
some options here. We have three input pins. And one of them is a boolean. I'm going to get
our locked and place that to connect up to the boolean. And then I'm going to set A. So
is it locked? So you can see locked pick A. So that's going to be the locked convention.
I'm going to come in here. I'm going to change our color to one and go okay. And then B. I'm
going to change our color to one and go okay as well. So you can see here we have locked
true or false yes or no. If it's true pick A which is red. If it's false pick B which is green.
So we've written a relatively small function which is reusable. Now I want to come to our
construction script drag our change light color in and plug that in. Now if I look in our viewport
you can see that it's set to green. You can also see that our instance in the world is set
to green as well. Now I have multiple doors. I'd quite like to be able to change if they are
locked or unlocked inside the browser. And to do that what I'm going to do is I'm going to come
to our locked variable and I'm going to click on it so that it becomes instance editable.
That means that little i is going to be visible next to the variable. And in the details panel
you can see the instance editable is going to be ticked off. Hit compile. And now if I select
one of these instances you can see in the detail panel I have the option of locked.
And if I tick that on you can see that our door turns red and I'm not on the other side as well.
So just changing this variable will rerun the construction script which will update the
color of the door. Now that's great. We can change the way that it looks.
However this will not have any effect. Ideally when the door is locked we don't we don't want
it to be able to be opened. So let's come into the door and let's implement that functionality.
I'm going to come back to our event crawl. I'm going to go to our E button. We'll drag this
back. Hold down B. Left click. And that will add in a branch.
Now we talked about branch. This is our if statement. If it is true do what is
connected to this pin. If it is false do what is connected to this pin. You might
drag in the lock and get it. Then connect it as the input to the branch. Then if it is locked
and true I don't want it to do anything. If it locked is false I want the door to open and close.
So now if this is set to locked we will block this function out. So let's test that out
in level. Come in here. Come up to the door on the left. Press P. The door does not open.
One in the middle. Door opens fine. And the one on the right is closed.
So you can see now we are capable of changing the settings on a specific instance and having
it do something different. So thank you for sticking with me through this. Next up we will
be moving on to creating an actor which communicates with the door to lock and unlock it.